i think if if you get pregnant it's the
hundred percent the girl's fault i don't
think that i feel like the men get very
little responsibility i'm gonna tell you
why okay
because i feel like we have so many
forms of birth control that we can be on
you can tell him to wear a condom
well then like don't consent to that i
mean like we're taking out take essay
off the table okay like if that if that
happens to you that is not your fault
that's that's a different different
conversation but if you're like doing it
with a normal guy
like most of them are going to like
listen to you if if you say no right but
take sesame off the table so i feel like
if you get pregnant it's your own fault
as a girl because we have so many forms
of birth control you can track your
cycle so you know when you're ovulating
you can
um you can wear a condom
so
like that all of that is on i feel like
the girls like think about it like why
is all contraception centered around the
woman i feel like that's another thing
that i feel like
like the woman kind of has to have like
if she wants to
get rid of that child like it's also on
the woman she has to go through that
whole thing i feel like there's not much
that the man has to the man has to go
through like the man doesn't have to
take any pills he doesn't have to get
like an implant doesn't have to take
anything i think men would if they had
it they just they just they just have it
that's actually the thing that is a male
um well i think you think drake he went
through the heart like he wouldn't take
that
like men don't want like kids running
around either
well like i heard there was again i
heard but like this was like a big um
thing going around this rumor of that
there was a male contraceptive pill but
it had the same side effects of the
female ones so they still left it in
production and still
are working on it now and haven't
released it because it has the same side
effects um of the female do you think
men would take it so if this was to come
out on the market do you think like men
would actually take contraception like a
pill or like get an implant like a lot
of women do i think
you know what i think it depends on a
guy i think there's a small percentage
you've got like because there aren't you
know you realize like most men aren't
sexually active
you want how tall do you want a guy to
be if you're gonna date him
taller than me how tall are you
i'm not sure
have you heard girls say they want a guy
over like six foot
like do you want to have that i've heard
a woman be like he's
five
ten or five nine nine yeah okay okay how
what percentage of guys do you think are
over six foot
and not many in the uk just to tell you
yeah in america yeah
so it's like 15 it's 18 actually i think
percent of guys that are over six foot
so it's a small and when women swipe
right on dating apps they swipe right on
less than 20 of guys and it's 80 of
women swipe right on 20 of guys so it's
a very small percentage of men that are
sexually active so i think that
i think that those guys probably would
because they don't want kids running
around maybe not nick cannon though
yeah i think it depends on the guy okay
i'm not gonna lie it depends on the guy
because um
these guys they ain't sexually active
they might
they might want a kid for the simple
fact that they ain't sexually active
let's say there's something else to do
yeah
let's see like
i don't know they
they just want something to love yeah
they're gonna want a kid yeah they're
gonna want a kid and it's like
[Music]
you can't
by the way is the woman's choice 100
1 000 because at the end of the day i
understand like i grew up around women
and i heard a bunch of conversations i
probably shouldn't have but
um
you guys go for a lot of pain
like a lot of physical pain forget the
emotional side of things i know you've
got guys before a lot of them
physical pain
but then again and i don't know if this
is just me being a guy
it's not our fault
it's not our fault like but like
you need to you kind of need a guy to
have that process
involved it's not even you both make
that decision to
do what you do
you both made that decision it's not
just the guy that says okay cool what
we're going to do today no
yeah both i get that like both people
are on board but like i still feel like
the the female part in this situation
just has like a completely different
experience so throughout the pregnancy
like oh yeah we're pregnant but like i'm
pregnant in a situation like you're
carrying the child like you're doing the
checkups
yeah like you're just you're just there
for moral support and that's yeah isn't
moral support good like when you're
upset don't you want your friends to be
dead i feel like if you're carrying like
how much is like a pregnant baby like
how much does that weigh like he's not
gonna like hold it so now look
let's say it wasn't like a baby let's
leave baby out the picture yeah let's
say you have a friend yeah and your
friend is um
i don't know your friend
stabbed his or her arm yeah okay and
they have to stay in the hospital for a
week
yeah you're gonna go and see it like
let's say this is a close close friend
are you my question to you is are you
going to go and see that friend every
day to make sure okay so like moral
support in that sense but that that's
different no no it's not it's not it
doesn't matter what sense it is i'm
saying
like at the end of the day
what
me as a man
what i'm doing for you
as a woman
should be appreciated as equally as what
you're actually going through i don't
think it should be appreciated the same
but like you can't do any more like you
you physically can't take the babies
that's exactly fair enough
i don't appreciate it like that you're
doing a bare minimum if you go to like
those visits but but it's kind of like
why are we diminishing like men being
involved in their kids lives like i
think that's almost diminishing it
i don't think it's diminishing but i
just think because men men pet like like
like the woman can
there's like it's good for the baby if
they hear the dad around and stuff you
know
and like men still have to financially
support it more times than not
i think that's true but like i do feel
like nothing will like it will never
match up like what the woman does in
that whole biological process in
comparison to what the man does like
physically we list the things physically
what did they do they're literally
carrying the child like nine months
other than carrying the child what did
they do
they're literally like using their own
body as like a life you realize like
dogs do that like everyone like
every every animal carries
like
reducing that a lot but i feel like
pregnancy is like a really like horrific
problem should i tell you why i said
what did they do because
this is what you don't no one really
talks about on the man's side
let's say it's your your it's not just a
random girl it's your your wife your
girlfriend whatever
do you know how much headache
do you know how much headache that man
has to go through
like mentally because he might be like
okay cool yeah i'm having a child
whatever yeah but at the same time it's
like this woman is pissing can i swear
yeah you can swear
this woman is pissing me off because
like like the hormonal changes yeah i
can't deal with this so that like for
the guys exactly for the guy to stick
there and not even just so go just to be
present is like well done
spotted
i mean yeah yeah fair like um a lot of
people have things where it's like their
dad doesn't turn up and stuff like it's
to be fair like
they shouldn't get a medal or a reward
but like just being there is kind of i
feel like the guy being there's like the
bare minimum like if they're both
concerned into having the child so
what's the maximum
the max there's no maximum exactly the
minimum and the maximum yeah
but why don't we why don't we like
pedestalize women for like doing what
they're supposed like you're
pedestalizing women right now because
you're saying we're carrying a child
it's this great thing like literally dog
dog dogs carry like like every animal
that i'm not going to pedicure yeah yeah
but i feel like
men don't have much opportunity to do
more so give your minimum maximum is
like the same level so if you turn up
and you're there that's like the best
you can do and also like the bare
minimum
helping with the pregnancy helping when
she's in bed like yeah be there then
leave then be there but if you're there
like there's different levels to it i
think do you like
a man that can cook
i like people that can take care of
themselves
cool so i'm taking that as a yes sir
yeah cool now do you appreciate
i don't know uh breakfast in bed from a
man yes you guys had a great night you
guys
you're still in bed you woke up before
you you wake up to
food fruit yeah your peanuts are nice
yeah that's nice that's right so
now the pregnancy
isn't that kind of the same thing
because and you're gonna appreciate that
because in your waking up thinking wrong
like i didn't even have to lift the
finger usually that's
quote-unquote the woman's job
yeah but you this guy has gone out his
way he didn't need to get out but he got
i made you food he just like he didn't
need to be around you for those nine
months where you were shouting off his
air
he's still there though because he
understands like the bigger picture like
the big picture is is after these nine
months i have a child to raise like
she's
she can do whatever she wants she can go
chill she can do whatever but
like
when the nine maps come
he's got chapters so that's why i asked
do you
appreciate the the the brexit
yeah because then you're saying that the
man being there's bare minimum but that
breakfast in bed think about he doesn't
need to do that so that's maximum
not maximum but i feel like it's
respectfully the bare minimum like if
you're just a trashy guy you can just
not be
[Music]
you're still saying the same thing
like i just feel like we always are
diminishing that
a question
do you guys ever think
what is he going through
yeah
and then what's your answer like once
you think what you're going through
like
what's the answer what's asking
questions and then find out like it
depends like what's going on what do you
mean like i'm single right now like what
you gone through you know true
you're talking about like a boyfriend
like what's he going through
let's just say
[Music]
um well that's what i talk about on my
channel is it advocates for men
so that's that's i talk about this a lot
like i had two brothers like try to
commit suicide
so i like men i don't know men
go through a lot i feel like men are
always like diminished in every
situation in life like we always
downplay like how like men
and even even like in this comment like
i'm not you know trying to correlate the
two but like even in this conversation
like you're down playing like men being
a father and how great that is like that
is a great it's a hard thing to do
um
and yeah i know i think about like men's
pro that's what i talk about all day
that's what i do for work
there you go i do think it's important
to recognize like what men go through
like i do like i do know it's like
obviously like
i love women i love to advocate for
women and obviously like i'm very
defensive towards women because i'm a
woman and i've gone through like the
experience of being a woman but i do
notice that like it's not easy to be a
man like to have to be expected to earn
a lot of money to be expected to provide
it's not that's a lot of pressure to go
through as a woman you can definitely
avoid that if you want to you see for me
yeah
my thing is not as if you have a vagina
or a penis i don't like i don't care
my thing is your human being
at the end of the day let's start there
usually when guys think about females to
talk about
um
like typically like they talk about um
emotions being emotional like that's
usually the thing
called now when females talk about guys
what like
what do you guys actually talk about
because
for me it's like
what can you guys actually say about us
because we don't like anything we do
it's just wrong like and like and when i
say anything we do is wrong in terms of
like if
as you said
going to the um pregnancy helping and
you said that's bare minimum for us it's
like bro do you know how much [ __ ] i
have to do yeah i am putting that [ __ ]
aside coming to you attending to you
and then you're going to tell me this is
the bare minimum in our heads we're like
[ __ ] this i'm not coming back
i'm going to go go work and go do what i
got to do for me
because
i'm not being appreciated here and i in
my opinion i think with most men wow
with most men
our thing is
we don't get appreciated at all
like i don't think that's true not at
all not at all we do get appreciated but
like
we
have like okay you see how women get
like a um
uh
a leeway if you know what i mean i feel
like it's not always leeway it's kind of
like pity sometimes like a lot of like
like when women are like my tyres broken
in my car like oh i'll help you i don't
think it's pretty it's just like oh
you're a woman you look nice yeah pity
like oh like she can't do it herself
i think i don't think men don't get that
men don't get that
most men that's not what we think that's
not what you think we're just thinking
oh she needs help she's a woman like let
me help because for us what's what's
kind of ingrained in us is just you need
to be a gentleman like that's kind of
ingrained we don't i kind of even i have
that
but i kind of have that with both like i
don't think of gender when i do that
there you go that's interesting
this is the thing i don't you're just a
human being someone needs help i'm like
yeah of course like you're gonna want to
help them and stuff like that there you
go so like my thing is like
with the appreciation though
going back to the the the pregnancy like
don't you think that we're going through
a lot more than
meets that
i do say that a pregnancy is very
centered around the woman the whole
experience is kind of like her
experience i do think there's obviously
things going on and concerns for the guy
but i do feel like the experience with a
woman is probably a lot more emotionally
demanding than the experience for the
man and i feel like just a general
process of having someone else growing
inside of you so basically you've got
two people there there's like two people
that's already like double the
experience so that's kind of like my
logic there but i do like obviously like
male people are going through different
things i don't understand that because
i've not gone through the male
experience obviously you can have
thoughts and emotional issues going
around like i don't know
i mean with those like parent parenting
classes um it's usually parent like both
the parents and they work with both of
them about how to like
help the kid and the baby and you know
stuff like that
i feel like maybe it is and also like
the dad still has the fear like i feel
like the thing about parents is fear
like it's fear of like
this
it better survive like yeah i like keep
this going but
yeah so i feel like that sometimes
that's kind of diminished sometimes like
the looks like a mum caring but it's
like the dad is also quite scared about
what's going on i can appreciate that i
heard this these parents that were like
literally like when my baby sleep and
sometimes i'm like
like i'm nudging sometimes it's like
like
so like women go through so much after
pregnancy like memory loss
like a lot of women experience they
can't sleep like they have to be like
physically like barely sleeping so they
can always like hear their child like i
feel like that's like like having no
sleep is like scientifically known to be
like really bad for your health that's
so stuff like that like and also like
your pension you won't get a pension on
maternity leave for a lot of jobs so if
you take time off to take care of your
child you don't have a pension so that
then again like maternity leave too they
do but yeah like in some countries they
have a longer maternity leave but in
most countries they don't really have
like a long potentially so they can keep
working still earn a pension those kind
of things like more financial stability
going for the situation like as a woman
if you're your partner you're really
dependent on them in that kind of time
well why is that a bad thing i'm not
saying it's a bad thing i'm just saying
it's like the ability that a woman has
to go through higher than the other man
in most situations but isn't that kind
of nice like if we want you know you're
20 right
you date a guy 20 years older than you
you could like not work the rest of your
life if you want it like that's it
do you think you could do that one more
time if if she wanted to she could date
a guy 20 years older than her and just
like not
and i said like like would you be able
to do that you think the thing is
the thing is